al'appel pas tous besoin de jeu
marseillais m'bia fatou c'est la mode de
chine merci c'est alors à coup patois
temps je tente mais tu vas pas me les
haut parleurs espèces d'hormones pas
comment ça marche oui bonjour à tous
allez tu en clientèle tu sais quoi la
fête où tu lui as pris ça que tu tombes
d'ibg mignot une fougasse aux olives
donne à comment tu l'as pas mal imité
machuca bien tu l'appelles dans la
dignité je ne l'appelle pas il a besoin
d'être en plus mais alors c'est vrai il
a noué un nouveau look je sais pas si tu
as vu ce soir on aimerait avoir ton avis
dessus donc tu rentres à la maison et tu
nous dis d'accord merci fatou à tous à
tout bon dans l'est ou du temps mais au
delà de l'union
[Applaudissements]
nous présidents atouts résident à tous
tout résident est alors l as tu sais que
là on a perdu gilles c'est énorme
elle et lui dit alors fatou je m'occupe
de tout d'accord je peux faire
l'animation se veut pour le mariage tu
viens tu te rends d'accord c'est pas du
gâteau
gilles ça à mon chéri alors ça tout jeu
j'aurai un team gym mais on te rappelles
tu embrasses s'allume open campagne
[Applaudissements]
font pas sans une bonne 9 0 dis moi j'ai
oublié tout faire notre avis arrive
c'est moi qui devais pas pêcher les
meufs à ta place avant ses routes et ses
moyens
mettez musique romantique pauline michel
ah ba les opérations mettez moi une
autre musique sort et on dirait qu'on
est dense à plano bande de ringards
mettez moi un truc important je vais
faire ça tout tu as saint gilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
la peau
et sans rigoler les mecs ça fait quatre
ans qu'on attend ça
il suffit je l'appelle elle s'orne la
boulangerie elle a des chouquettes ici
une fougasse allemand faire à la deux
baguettes viennoise et fahem dit oui ça
avance
on nous a sorti s'abîme suis pris un
coup là dans les jambes je te jure c'est
vrai dont il fournit le dossier en main
mais c'est bon terreau comprenait pas ce
que tu me laisses gérer ce dossier
ah oui oui parce que cela je vous dire
la vérité et je pense que les
téléspectateurs sont dit la même chose à
un moment
fatouma dit et ça m'a fait extrêmement
plaisir elle m'a dit je vais venir te
voir alors je veux bien je vois pas en
fait ce que j'ai à faire dans ces
différents domaines
j'aime beaucoup et si vous êtes car ils
étaient bien reprendre comme témoin
voilà à vous elle vous parle plus qu'à
moi non c'est vrai pourquoi mais oui
elle est plus imposé vous les bonnes
questions
je vois là mais opposé mulemo question
bernard lagoutte moi j'ai plein d'amis
j'aime et je dors pas ta carrière que ce
soit en deux mois il ya une fusion est
reconnu olala c'est la réunion d'un
volcan d'auvergne d'une volvic et je vis
la maison